- So, would you be up for us
just maybe takin' a couple
questions
- Absolutely!
Yes, please!
- Okay.
Well, where is Ramsey?
Where's Ramsey?
Hi!
- Hi, Kelly. Hi, Jessica.
- What's your question?
- So, Jessica I heard that
you were in a car accident
and you quoted, "My
stutter started soon after
"and the doctors said it
was from the head injury.
"My mom said that when I stuttered
"it looked like my brain and I were trying
"to say ten things at once."
"My voice just wouldn't work."
So, from this trauma, why
did you go into singing?
- That, actually singing was the best way
for me to communicate.
- I've heard about that with stutter.
- So I got into singing and
that was literally the way
that I could express myself
and how everything, like, was clear.
So, yeah, I don't what
caused the stuttering.
I mean it could've been
from the car accident,
something you know,
trauma.
- Traumatic.
- Like, very traumatic.
Other traumatic things that I
went through as a child but,
and I also have a million
thoughts in my head at all times.
- Me too.
- Like somehow
trying to balance that
I might as well just sing through it.
- I love that.
I love that, great question.
(laughs)
So next question though
is from Ashley, right?
Where's Ashley at?
Hi, Ashley.
- Hi, Kelly. Hi, Jessica.
So you talk about being sober
and you're actually just
speaking about that now,
what brought you to the point
where you felt like you had to get sober?
- Well, being a mother.
Like, I mean my kids at the
time were five and four.
So, I grew up with no alcohol
in the house and I was,
but I mean I was at a place
where I was literally like,
spiraling with the alcohol, like,
and I was missing out moments of,
like, missing out on
moments with my children
and then they were seeing me
and they were very confused
and I just wanted to be present
and have clarity and be a good
role model for my children.
'Cause I've always wanted
to be a good role model
for the world, so why in
the world would I like,
be stuck in this cycle of having
to like wake up and have
a drink before going
to one of their school assemblies.
It got to the point where
all of my life had like, escalated
and I couldn't suppress it and alcohol,
it wasn't working.
It was making me just
completely check out.